parfois ils assoient oui comme tous les
jours après leur travail frédéric et
emmanuel change d'univers
les voilà partis en chasse une chasse un
peu particulière
tous deux sont photographes et c'est une
longue histoire
depuis leur adolescence il observer les
animaux et les photographies chacun de
leur côté
il ya quinze ans ils se rencontrent ils
vivent alors leurs passions ensemble
bon tu vas dans la fuite du fonds moi je
vais être là et puis mata l'heure les
bonnes chances
matelas
arrivé là le ton est donné
faire le moins de bruit possible à notre
caméra aussi d'être discrète pour
s'approcher au plus près des animaux
frédéric s'installe dans un affût
flottant un petit abri qui va lui servir
de camouflage l'afflux est en place
depuis depuis la mi juin
on change de place régulièrement pour
pas que les animaux c'est habituel voies
à cet endroit donc comme ça nous on peut
on peut bouger sur les tons les animaux
sont habitués c'est ainsi que frédéric à
réaliser ces clichés magnifiques des
scènes de vie au bord des étangs de
cette si belle sologne encore préservée
à force de persévérer de persévérer on
peut faire des images des images des
images
et puis un jour et la séquence
exceptionnelle
[Musique]
pendant ce temps là emmanuel rejoint un
autre à fut fixé celui là quand tout à
coup au détour d'une allée des biches un
fond et un jeune cerf comme ça ça cache
pas la couleur
puis sous une distance assez limité pour
une fois je vois que depuis six mois
donc
celui-ci était posée au moins 2 au mois
de juillet entre temps les taux
rabaissés
il passe devant même sur le côté et a
aucun souci ils sont vraiment habituel
bataille appliquées à temps
ça peut sortir que des temps sur le côté
un jeune cerf puis un autre plus âgé
ils ne font que passer mais emmanuel
déclenché
elle restera poster ici près de trois
heures c'est des heures et des heures
mais quand on a l'image qui arrivait
qu'on souhaite égouts éventuellement
qu'on arrive et on les compte plus du
tout c'est fini
la pudeur et c'est que du bonheur depuis
dix ans nos photographes se passionne
pour le cerf roi de la forêt ils
viennent d'ailleurs de lui consacrer un
livre
le ser hormis la période du brame google
il est très visible le reste de l'année
le serbe devenu un fantôme en septembre
c'est quand même ce mammifère qui fait
que la forêt prend tout son sens c'est
le bruit le brame l'allèle forez vit
alors une autre les oiseaux bien sûr
mais le fait d'entendre le cerf bras
mais c'est quelque chose d'exceptionnel
même si on le voit pas longtemps ça
c'est super puis toute cette mise en
scène qui se fait avec les bij me sert
ainsi tu sais c'est un peu de la magie
derniers clichés avec cette famille de
sangliers la nuit après leur séance mais
nul doute que demain
fredreik emmanuel reviendrons sur ce
territoire